whoa is that the reject nation they
snuck up on us I'm Greg I'm squirt John
cork John well guys we're going to do
the movie news of the week of July 23rd
to the 28th okay ready
Maya ready play the top stories hey can
I get more stories that's the way this
works but anyway we'll cover the top two
for you guys on go to guys did you hear
Wonder Woman is gained serious Oscar
campaign consideration and all that fun
stuff isn't that exciting guys you know
I think this information is interesting
this is a short before looking balls
about this everyone's covering this
story this week I feel I guess that's
good news I don't see it having a shot
at actually winning
I could see it getting nominated for
some stuff the main considerations they
want you know Best Supporting Actress
time that's actually won Best Director
patty Jenkins and Best Picture those are
the main campaigns are shooting for I
feel like if anything with comic book
movies especially the more likely to win
for like Best Coffee design yeah that's
production resident effect so yeah check
the technicals their technical side
craft stuff I don't know about best
picture of it I can see it getting a
Best Picture nomination but I feel like
out of any of these main categories or
looking to get I could see patty Jenkins
getting a Best Director nomination you
know yeah all the political reasons
behind it especially you know Oscars can
be a rather political and some they also
try to satisfy a lot of white dude yeah
and the follow yours love black people
the women it like they try to get
politically correct they try to satisfy
their more younger and more diverse
audience now they have with the Oscars
and the people that vote it's not a bad
thing at all because you know they have
the biggest voices right now they're the
people watching the actual exactly patty
Jenkins the Wonder Woman I thought was
great and beautifully directed
wonderfully shot had a lot of heart and
soul Mia it's not a Wonder Woman review
the Oscar movie season hasn't debuted
upon us this year yet because Wonder
Woman was a summer blockbuster but keep
in mind that max fury road while not a
combat movie was a major summer
blockbuster that took home like six
Oscars out here and it was a best
your nominee as well so I don't see why
Wonder Woman doesn't have a shot at
getting nominated for Best Picture
but if anything it should at least get a
Best Director nomination yeah I would be
happy about that
the thing about Wonder Woman is like
there to me there is still thing like
well I adore a lot of things about that
movie like at the end of the day it's a
comic book movie like it's a superhero
movie and it follows into some of those
traps towards the end stuff that picture
to me is a little bit of a stretch I'm
like I love that movie but it's just not
the kind of film that I think of and I
think there are movies that have
executed better yeah at least in terms
of the whole movie aside from the
content well it's a very culturally
impactful film I think it's one of those
superhero films that will be talked
about decades from now so it's kind of
like how the Dark Knight is I think yeah
it's great and it is important so I
would like to see a lot of Oscar love
for whatever and I think Patti Jang is
getting a Best Director not would be a
good way to do that because it seems
pretty clear that her influence over
that movie was huge like like so it
seemed like she really guided that film
should also be the first woman to be
nominated Kathryn Bigelow for The Hurt
Locker hello how cool would it be if
Patti Jenkins gets nominated and then
Kathryn Bigelow for Detroit Roy oh dude
yeah women are taking over Oh Trump you
must be worried the Oscars sad so biased
I got the best movies guys guess what
James Cameron otherwise out is Jimmy
Jimmy see ya JC is about to get the
rights back for terminator and he is
eyeing a potential continuation the
franchise maybe even a new trilogy the
question is to quote their question is
how does the franchise run its course or
can it be freshened up so I own
discussion with David Ellison who is the
current rights holder globally for the
Terminator franchise and the rights in
the US market revert to me under US
copyright law in a year and a half is
this like an official statement he wrote
or does he just speak that eloquently so
he and I are talking about what we can
do right now we are leading sort of a
doing a three film arc and reinventing
it
okay here's what I got to say about this
the only way I think fans would be
excited about another Terminator movie
because Terminator Genisys flopped and
rightfully so - yeah vertically made on
the very homage to the movie box office
bomb makes sense especially since during
the prior two movies were also bad
having James Cameron step into the next
maybe not as directing it but being one
of the creative heads on it playing like
the Kevin Feige Florida Terminator
movies or something what makes the most
of because James Cameron is the only one
who's made good Terminator films don't
know what has done it he invented the
world invented the Lord invented all of
a brought Armel to it so James Cameron
being involved in it I think would be
awesome the question is this James
Cameron really had ideas for what he
could do it seemed like you pretty much
wrapped up the movie would terminator -
well oh here we go
or does he just going to try to go in
there do course correction or it can
even let it die I think James Cameron
doing it I would be more interested and
more excited for it because I feel like
he's the only human being who can do it
except for you know like denis
villeneuve it i don't know if they could
do any project honestly to give you is
to be completely honest I'm not really
excited about this news I like the idea
of a trilogy I don't because to me one
wasn't planned to be sequels in
Terminator 2 was meant to end it yeah I
generally trust James Carey I'm worried
about this because you know we've
started to see it more and more like you
know Ridley Scott is a prime example of
why I'm worried about something like
this because you know it's like yes your
beloved franchise I get it but unless
you really have a great idea yeah I
don't think we need this and you know
it's a good opportunity there will
always be a craving for another good
Terminator movie that I'm sort of with
you I'm like what's the driving
motivation what's left to tell and I
like again I generally trust James
Cameron's judgment he seems like a guy
like even avatar which I don't really
care for a lot of people don't even
really care for like you know at least
made a bold impact with that movie he
came out and with that whole thing about
Terminator Genisys being like no this
one yeah that
kind of put a weird taste in my mouth in
terms of him and terminator we really
have to see what his plans are get you
know the worry is it certain or to had
ground Britta give you that word is not
applied lightly with Terminator 2 that
was groundbreaking special effects what
made that film so special beyond the
special effects was expanding the
mythology expanding the world this
storytelling all of those pieces
everything is taught enough everything
in that movie is top-notch in story and
character keen primary before the
special effects yeah and not much in a
lot of the the reasons you know yeah in
the later sequels is top-notch aside
from maybe some of the technology they
use to make them and then when you look
at people like Peter Jackson with The
Hobbit or Ridley Scott or even James
Cameron doing avatar you know I feel
like I can be more forgiving on because
those brand new technology was like a
major experiment he was doing with that
film one for a while he's been like I
want to expand this yeah thank you yeah
exactly
I feel like the Terminator is this going
to just be some huge CGI thing you're
experimenting with again or is this
going to be something where you're
really going to be invested in this
story Tom because right now I feel like
there's nothing left to tell I don't
know you're the inventor of Terminator
you have a better judgment than I did
this rings to me like yeah why not more
than like no no I want to do this yeah
and I feel like the only real reason now
especially to touch terminator again is
if they really want to and they have a
great idea yeah well guys those were the
most interesting stories we can find
this week true that a lot after
comic-con that's that exciting nope
subscribe to the real rejects quick the
notification valve - on Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram and check out our
patreon for exclusive perks and rewards
and every week in extended version of
our movie news segment and there's more
than that but yeah